former Vice President Joe Biden's loss
of his son Beau had a big impact on his
personal and political life Joe Biden
died more than two years ago after a
battle with brain cancer
the tragedy came as the vice president
faced a decision on whether to run for
president in 2016 in his new book
promised me to add a year of Hope
hardship and purpose the elder Biden
chronicles that momentous and
challenging time we welcome Vice
President Joe Biden to here in studio 57
so nice to see you need to be back we're
gonna talk about the book because it's
such a terrific book and those legacy as
well but I want to ask you first about
the big political news Doug Jones the
Democrat winning in Alabama what message
does that send sends a message that not
only did they reject the all the Luther
strange stood for in terms of his
attitude toward women but more yeah well
I mean excuse me learn more but but it
also Doug talked about the issues he
cares about I've known Doug since he was
in law school he worked with me I went
down a campaign for him and you know the
last you talked to him yeah three what I
talked to him three times yesterday
because he was so giddy well he's over
the moon and he's really anxious to get
to work if you notice he talked about
last night he talked about children's
health care you know with all his
excitement he didn't go after Morrie
talking about children's health care
this is a guy who was a serious serious
guy a great prosecutor a man of great
integrity he also said something very
interesting I thought mr. Biden at the
at his victory conference he said what
happened in Alabama shows that we can be
united in this country do you think it
will send this message to the rest of
the country both Democrats and
Republicans well I think it is and I
think probably some of the happiest
people in America today the Republicans
in the Senate know iiiiii genuinely meet
now we talked about explain what you
mean by that well
that the the divisiveness that that was
caused within the Republican Party by
bana and all the sort of bile that comes
out of the administration that this
assist and I I know the majority of the
members of the Senate Republican side
and a decent people they don't they're
not comfortable in this territory did
you give him advice in one of these
three phone calls well I gave him advice
early on because he keep called me I
mean he look he's been a he was a young
man when he started working for me and
helping me and I've been so damn proud
of him the way he prosecuted those cases
there were fifty years old and and he's
really a smart guy so the advice my
advice and he didn't need it was focus
on the issues why you want to be the
United States Senator what you're going
to do for Alabamians and and if you
notice both the bulk of what he did was
that and last night instead of taking
the victory lap like a lot of Democrats
might want him to do go out and say you
know this is a big loss for the
president which it is he talked about
bringing people together and he that's
who the kid that his kid got I know but
he worked for you on your 88 president
yeah he did and we've stayed friends and
you know I was good friends with how
half lemon I'm down in Tuscumbia Alabama
with how and so but it's a you know he's
he's some great he's a serious serious
guy you used to tell a story about when
you were a kid and entering the Senate
and Senator Mansfield said to you look
around at all these centers somebody
sent them here and to find the good in
them is that still possible in politics
it's necessary it's absolutely
positively necessary but you know the
way we've gotten because of
gerrymandering and unlimited spending in
campaigns
I mean we've gotten the point we don't
know each other we don't know one
another when you know somebody when you
know somebody has had prostate cancer or
they got a child with a drug problem or
they have no matter what the position is
on an issue and you don't it's not one
you start off disliking them you
actually have a connection and these
guys don't real quick story I want ice
to go up you know every time we'd be in
trouble administration I go up and talk
to the the members of the Senate I went
up to the Senate dining room the private
dining room we
to get together and talk Democrats it's
gone there's no tables there anymore
there's no place to sit knee it's a
metaphor for just how how different
things are we do see anything in this in
this Trump administration in the Trump
White House where you can say you know
what they're doing a good job on X Y & Z
well I do think they're doing a decent
job but the UN with regard to North
Korea I think there's a number of things
that are there on the on the cusp of
doing good things but the I wish the
president would be President I mean and
stop being so consumed with himself and
his and his image I mean it's a there's
there's so much it's I guess the thing
that bothers me the most Gayle is that
America has always led by the example
not of its power but the power of its
example and we are decimating that
around the world I have more heads of
state calling me this day what's you
know explain what's this about so I
don't know I think there are a number of
things that could be worked on together
and even those where there's bitter
disagreement like the tax bill there's
no need to be so personal and did you
have anything the National arms piece
about how this isn't spends his time if
that's true it's really sad it's just
sad that someone would view everything
in terms of a reality show and
everything in term and say that it's
hard to believe to me that he says that
to somebody but the idea it manat about
Donald Trump it's about America it's it
just I've never seen anything quite like
this um
you write about so many things in this
book including your son Beau and you
also talk about teaching your
granddaughter in the face of wrongdoing
that quotes silence is complicity we now
have a hundred congressional Democrats
are calling on to investigate president
Trump's alleged sexual misconduct do you
think there should be an investigation
I look these women deserve to be heard I
wrote the Violence Against Women Act a
long time ago
talking about that but I had a provision
in it that was struck down by the
conservative Court it provided for a
woman to have a civil cause of action if
she was harassed or abused so she didn't
have to count on the legal system to to
take her case it was struck down imagine
if there were still a civil cause of
action that existed that would allow
women have a civil rights cause of
action to go into court and say this is
what this man president or not did to me
and when President Trump tweets that
Senator Gillibrand would do anything for
a campaign contribution how did you take
that it's disgusting
I never thought I'd say that about a
prayer
it's disgusting it's absolutely and our
children are listening yeah they really
are
what makes it David Brooks has written a
lot of good stuff he talked about about
how there was just an invisible moral
fabric that holds up this society and
and you can either sew it together or
shred it these guys are shredding it in
order to make room for them to be able
to abuse power and I just it's so
beneath well I should this is David
Brooks likes a lot about character too
and I wanted to talk about your
character you and Barack Obama the
friendship the relationship you have was
very evident when while you were in the
White House and I'm wondering if it
still continues today but I'm struck by
his words that he said to you how do you
want to spend the rest of your life do
you all use that friendship continues
today it does I start we talk to each
other a lot and we see each other I kid
him I said I don't know how the hell you
have so much time to play golf joke and
because he always sees calls and play
golf and but it does continue and the
thing I'm proudest of in the eight years
I mean this is a man I've served with a
presence and I got to know four of them
very well I've never met any president
that has more character more integrity
and more backbone when this guy does it
was an honor serving with him and eight
years not a hint not a hint a scandal
2020s coming
how will you be serving your time I saw
you last night at the Sandy Hook gala
Sandy Hook promise and everybody was
saying Joe we miss you Joe we want you
to run I saw that constant conversation
in today you say well you know my dad
used to have an expression they say
don't compare me almighty compare me the
alternative so maybe that's why they're
same run but look I'm not doing anything
about it now my word as a Biden I'm not
doing anything about it if I got offered
the job this moment by the Lord Almighty
I say no because I don't know where
things are gonna be in the next two
years with my family with Rick and then
whether there's some really good talent
coming up but I'm not saying I wouldn't
run but I'm given my word there's
nothing I'm doing now to put myself in a
position to do that but I'm gonna be
involved